My goodness, AlphaGeometry, an
amazing Google DeepMind paper
fresh out of the oven. And I think this
paper might be history in the making. So,
how is an AI that learned on a 100,000,000
mathematical problems able to compete in the
International Mathematical Olympiad? That is
perhaps the most prestigious math competition
in the world. So, did they achieve a
breakthrough? Well, let’s see together.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now, competing on such problems is trouble. This
requires not just a huge glorified calculator for
adding numbers, but it requires planning your
solution, logic and reasoning. And more. But,
of course, GPT-4 can do all of that, so just give
the problems to it and and off you go. End of the
video, right? Just as a demonstration, GPT-4
can ace the bar exam, would be hired to Amazon
for its coding skills, and it is better than
almost all of humans on the biological olympiad.
So, it can sweep all of these, easy, right?
Well, let’s see, if you try to use GPT-4 and
give it 30 of these tasks, it can solve
exactly…wow. It can solve zero of them.
I hope this gives you a feel of how difficult
these problems are. Devilishly difficult. And
scientists at DeepMind just proposed a system that
is about a 100 times smaller? I can’t believe it.
But to start, how do you even solve such a
problem? Let’s see an easy example. For instance,
if we ask a human mathematician to prove
that there is an infinite number of primes,
we could prove it by listing them. But no
one can list an infinite amount of numbers,
that is impossible. No. So what do we do
instead? How do we do the impossible? Well,
instead we start with the assumption
that there is a finite number of primes,
and then find a contradiction that says
this assumption cannot possibly be true.
This part of the proof requires thinking
out of the box. It requires a moment of
brilliance. And without it, the problem is
intractable. It is akin to pulling a rabbit
out of your hat. And when you have the rabbit,
mechanically finishing the problem is relatively
easy. And the strategy could be that if the
rabbit didn’t work, try to pick a new one.
We can do that. But, can an AI, can a machine
pull a rabbit out of a hat? And the initial
answer is no. Mostly not. But let’s try
anyway. This is how a human would do it,
and here is their proposed AI
that could hopefully try to do it.
So, does it work? Well, let’s have a look.
When given a problem, with blue, it first
creates the key ideas, the rabbit, and then, the
green part is the remainder of the calculation
that leads to the solution. Okay, but this was
easy peasy. Now give me some proper problems.
Oh my, now we’re talking! So, little AI,
can you solve this? Whoa, it pulls the
blue rabbit out of the hat, and then, runs
the green calculations until it solves it.
And make no mistake, this is just an excerpt of
the solution. Now hold on to your papers Fellow
Scholars, because the full solution looks
more like this. My goodness, look at that.
More than a hundred steps have been concealed
here. And it had done all of this correctly.
And that is not even the longest proof it
is capable of writing. Not even close. Wow.
So, how good is it? Well, a previous technique
was this good, and the new technique without
the rabbit is this good. So it is almost as good
as the average mathematical olympiad contestant.
Note that these are really smart people, so the
average of those is also really smart. And it
can compete with that. But, wait a second.
This can run the mechanical calculations,
but it only takes you so far. You also need the
brilliance to pull the rabbit out of the hat.
And as soon as we add the rabbit part of the
solution, what happens? What? Are you seeing
what I am seeing? It is nearly as good as
the smartest of these super smart people.
And, Fellow Scholars, if you think that is
impressive, hold on to your papers because
we are just getting started. Here are
2 mind-blowing facts about the paper:
One, it learned from scratch by itself, without
any human demonstrations. Yes, the proposed system
does all this without human intervention. This
is essentially an AI implementation of the two
modes of human thinking, and that is thinking
fast and slow. Thinking fast is about quick,
instinctive responses, like reading something,
while thinking slow involves deliberate, logical,
and calculated decision-making. This can do both
as well as some of the smartest humans can do.
So when we are worried that this
cannot possibly get any better,
because there are no humans good enough to
teach it anymore, now we know that it only
needs synthetic training data, so it can learn
by itself. And it has already found more general,
more elegant solutions for some
of the tasks than humans did.
Two, this project is open source from day 1.
Every piece of the solution is out there for you,
for free. Yes, you Fellow Scholars
can run your own experiments with it.
And all this with a model that is about a
100 times smaller than GPT-4. An absolute
slam dunk of a paper. We are still early, but
I think it might be fair to say that this is a
breakthrough. Now, as incredible as this AI is,
note that it is still relatively narrow. It can
do geometry, but it cannot play StarCraft or do
anything else. However, the ideas and concepts
described in the paper are general enough to make
sure that this can be applied to other problem
domains as well. And that, Fellow Scholars, is
going to be a series of incredible breakthroughs.
By the way, it is a possibility that I will visit
San Francisco around mid April. For the first time
ever. If this is the case, if you are a local lab
like DeepMind and OpenAI and you would like me
to visit, or if there is someone who I should
really meet, please let me know on Twitter/X.